I love you so much and it really meant a
lot to me because of the bond that we
all share together I love all you boys
but that was really special for me
honest honest to God I mean that I
really do mean
that welcome back to careful boys where
we are very afraid of everything and one
of the things that I think we're most
afraid of
recently do Anthony Lee's beliefs about
the 9/11 attacks make us
uncomfortable serious right now we
really doing that we're not doing this
for [__] 20 minutes yeah we are dude
get ready personally uncomfortable can I
go first can we go over what the beliefs
are first yeah what are the beliefs what
are the beliefs Anthony I don't Lee I
believe that happened debunked move on
who we got and we're actually talking
about what we love about each other I
don't want to do this are you being
serious now do this dead serious wanted
to see what happened dead serious sex
this would have been like you take your
girl hey check this
out and then you're like I'm going go
down oh no no no if you do that Bart if
you do that to her [__] she came
already this guy ises puss dude you want
to
know damn what is happening I don't know
what was the question that just crazy do
Anthony Le Bel about the no that's not
the real one oh does it make you
uncomfortable that is the real one it
doesn't make me uncomfortable me too I'm
open I'm I'm accepting everything I'm
open but what's I feel like we're very
diverse here people go like oh JK you
guys just all [__] think the same I
mean I don't believe in Anthony's belief
about the 9/11 not ever happening CU I
saw it happen can I just ask how the
[__] did this happen you were gone one
day obviously and then we just started
going don't even ask because it's going
to turn into a tattoo for some
reason but you have us has a special
dance that it's interpretive dancing
showing the world
exactly that 9/11 never really happened
and according to Joe you do a Michael
Jackson lean but you come back up
because the towers came up too he had a
dance about how 911 is not real that
made me
weep he took two of the tallest guys and
K just he copied a little bit of that
like Smooth Criminal Michael Jackson
move when they like lean like that but
then in his story The Towers come back
up the well the the the all the tow
didn't drop like this because I believe
they dropped like this so how would you
do my
demolition wa spicy why is that harder
to swallow yeah why is that so hard to
believe that's too
real I like it better when you's the
what's the real yeah what's the real no
the real topic is yeah what do we love
about each other and for me it's like I
love that he thinks 911 didn't happen
it's fine I'm accepting I love that he
stands by his gun I love that it
actually says to anon's beliefs about
the 911 attack make us uncomfortable
that's the real problem that's the
problem yeah that's the problem giving
the people what they want man I also
like that too I think it's pretty
inspiring at least like you know what I
I I do like it but it doses when he
talks about it hey did I not say this
morning you would love our topic later
on about I thought that was about the
T-shirt not everybody is willing to like
die on that hill and also like usually
it's fine and I have a good time talking
to him about it but when he talks about
it too much it does make me feel a
little well he's not he doesn't pressure
you which is nice sometimes he does when
he's on when he's on one yeah off camera
when I always bring it up yeah yeah in
between every single take yeah and I'm
worried for our workout tomorrow morning
cuz I think's look to the fans and say
that that you truly believe that that
happens and don't lie to them because we
care about them tomorrow me and anth
going to work out and I'm just worried
how much of the conversation will be
about 9/11 that's fair one of my
favorite memories and this is being
completely honest one my favorite
memories recently is going to Anthony's
Val renewal ceremony we hugged each
other it was beautiful I we immediately
by the way rolled up the sleeve we
showed the tats off everybody at the
wedding party was like yo why do you
guys have matching tats did we like Twin
Towers yes no then while Anthony was
hugging me he's like did you watch the
documentary I was like
J here we go stop sending why is it got
to be that why is it got to be that this
is a beautiful moment did you watch the
documentary Ryan told me that last week
he was you know how he went to the east
coast but you know how we don't like
mentioning the east coast to Anthony cuz
that just always brings up the 911 talk
so then espe manhatt yo I had a blast
when I was in New York blast is scary
too yeah but he's like but I can't say
anything I don't want to do a OTR about
my New York trip cuz then Anthony is
going to be like bro it's triggering
yeah yeah anthy's like do you guys know
what what thermite is and I'm like here
we here we [__] here's the next two
hours of my [__] guys work out
tomorrow what if he's like all right
let's do nine sets of 11 round yeah
exactly I'll be like dude I know what
you're doing did you do them or did they
never happen or the worst thing this
happens twice a day he's like you guys
see what time it is I'm like yeah I know
yeah it's 911 twice a day I'm like yeah
I know I think the worst for me is
whenever we mention anything seven he
goes oh well building seven went off on
its own wait bill so building seven did
go down yeah but the other to was
Demolition what the hell whatever that's
a crazy one yeah I don't know man it's
kind of hard okay get your [__] facts
straight was it 911 never happened or it
was Demolition wait you tell us set the
record straight you change all the time
you're like you're like one of those
vegans that like one day catch you
eating eggs and I'm like wait what the
[__] was this he's like a a large Tower
swan in the wind he's like a big tower
swan in the wind so I never know built
for that what is your definition of
vegetarian yeah what's what do you mean
by show me the proof
what would be what would be enough proof
my situation what is enough proof what
is show the proof what does that when
you say show me the proof I just want
our fans to have the context that this
is our 21st video at 600 p.m. and we've
been drinking so we apologize who's been
drinking has he been drinking I don't
drink I'm sober as a bird this is this
is literally what is this okay first of
all this is your and this is your woo
coaster
guys I like woo yeah I own it he has a
woo coaster it it's on my I'm a fan yeah
thank you we're all the fans so what's
enough what would you say what's enough
proof what's enough
evidence does your What does what does
Nina think about all this what does she
say about this don't bring her into this
conversation man up and just talk to
me wow dude that sounds like a
deflection doesn't it yeah that's a
deflection it sounds like a protection
all right that's what it is all right
well maybe because the brain The
Mastermind
is what so we're going to start with B
all starts with I'll I'll cosign if
Nina's the
master that's a totally different bit
under the bus we're going to start with
Bart does it make you uncomfortable and
why and this is like maybe you know are
we really still yeah I guess so think we
should well to me anony is like a good
vegan right where he just Minds his own
business yep he doesn't try to force
those beliefs on you which is really
good and you can kind of sit at the same
dinner table where like you know every
time we go to New York together I salute
he gives the double bird oh my God and
I'm like that's fine we're like next to
each other and it's completely cool you
know I feel very patriotic and he goes
this guy's tripping but afterwards we
can still both get Halal Guys together
that's pretty cool yeah it's pretty
awesome every time you go to New York
together we go there yearly yep I go to
pay homage we always go on September
yeah he goes to to like see if there's
any new evidence or whatever and he's
like I don't ever see anything ever new
evidence true what nobody says that by
the way I did watch Loose Change um I
did too me too I tried per your
recommendation um through the link that
you sent us via
tour of pyro bay.com
and it was very compelling I'd have to
say the voiceover is a little weak yeah
sound like a 13-year-old kid yeah but
yeah compelling evidence Fair yeah but I
think what Anthony does is he takes it a
step further and instead of saying it
was an inside job somebody say many
steps further it's not even an inside
job anymore it's just like it just
didn't
happen if this makes it to one person
who was actually negatively affected and
they out of context think that I really
don't think that their [__] son died
or some [__] oh no that's true you guys
are honestly the [__] worst human
beings on YouTube that's true are we no
or is it
you we're just talking about what our
experien is with you
yeah that's all it really is and it's
just how your beliefs make us feel so
stop making about you Anthony it's about
us it's
called Munch Housen by
proxy just
remember [__] Nina's The
Mastermind no okay rapid fire why do we
love Anthony Lee let's go all right yeah
equally as bad you're awesome dude I'll
tell you this I was at your wedding um
th renewal rolling up my rolling up this
and and owning the tattoo with you was
one of the great you guys actually
exposed we did that's tight wish I could
have been there to witness I love you so
much and it really meant a lot to me
because of the bond that we all share
together I love all you boys but that
was really special for me honest honest
to God I mean that didn't mean that
today's video is brought to you by
Uncommon Goods do you face this
indecisive decision making when it comes
to holiday gift time and you go I don't
know what to get this is giving a stress
I'm just not even going to go to the
party well from now on you can go to all
Christmas parties because you could go
to Uncommon Goods and get some really
Uncommon Goods and what better way to
bring a cool gift and also support your
local business people local artists so
you stop giving money to those
billionaires anyways you got poor people
like us that need people investing and
check it out this is aemi donut kit yep
by Mr chef mimoto and I don't think he's
poor by any means but compared to Jeff
bezel he is and if you look into here oh
my goodness you can make he signatured
it wow you can make your own it's got
matcha for your Japanese lovers it's got
cocoa for all you chocolate lovers it's
got strawberry for all you fruit lovers
we got every kinds of things
confectionary powder and sugars with
confectionary stuffing it's got a lot of
great things so whether you buy it for
yourself or a friend or family member
it's a great way to switch it up this
holiday season your cooking Adventure
Starts Now to get 15% off your next gift
go to uncommongoods.com sloff theer
that's uncommongoods.com sloff theer for
15% off don't miss out on this limited
time offer Uncommon Goods we're all out
of the ordinary so you guys K my
emotions are on a roller coaster no I'm
I'm tell
you now he's eating me out the first
[__] 10 minutes was this oh I passed
the 91 Mark oh first 10 minutes he was
doing this and now I'm getting eat now
no I mean it great my vagina's cooking
yeah dude your moist it's called
foreplay baby it was no it's fun because
I watched all these people just in
bewilderment sort of lock in and be like
wow these guys have some sort of bond
some sort of crazy ass so they they no
one knew no no except Lawrence C lawence
Cal for sure got it well Lawrence knew
like I would say five other people knew
but like the majority of the people
there didn't know and then they they
were just like why you guys have
matching tattoos and and did it look
like you guys were part of a gang yeah
well then outside like one of uh one of
like the wedding party friends was like
why do you guys have matching tattoos
it's kind of crazy and [__] and I was
like oh well you know we we uh you know
we're on the stupid show together that
everyone thinks that's why we always
preface then I was like you know what
too like honestly like me and him been
through a lot together like we were
riding crypto together and stuff like
that and he's like a brother to me
that's what I said I mean I meant it I
really did I really I really do feel
that
that's a going down part I do go ahead
that's that part's with it no take it
away from me just cuz I called you 911
tonight for 11 minutes go ahead take it
away from me more like 11
videos um no what next why do we love
Anthony um my favorite thing is that cuz
as long as I've known Anthony he really
hasn't changed he's like you wouldn't
think after that much like success that
you'd still be like the same dude like
you really are very similar to when I
first knew you back when in college wow
still an idiot so but like so down to
earth and so relatable but like you
could have easily not been you know you
went through a lot of like really cool
[__] in your
life that's very true what is happening
no I met so I met Anthony sneak attack
it's true though from the back I first
got to know Anthony at our Stanford show
yeah one of the most coolest down toe
people I've ever met disagree and then
so that's why we iMed clicked and then
we see him build his first kindas Dojo
never changed then you guys did get a
[__] crazy ass complex and at that
time it's like on top of the world and
it would have any every reason to kind
of be like I'm like getting higher and
higher than everyone and then you know
people start big timing people never
felt that way it was just more more love
and be like yo come check it out this is
[__] cool this is like the coolest
thing I've ever done so far and just
like even with the Nike shoe deal just
like all kinds of cool [__] it was like
the world is getting bigger and bigger
bigger and it it always felt like you're
the most down toe guy and still the same
dude that I met you forgot to plug the
noodles and kab bang noodles that's true
he kept doing mad [__] when we were
falling apart and then it was so fun to
uh actually be failing and taking down a
winner taking this guy down with us yeah
it was fun it was taking down a winner
how the turntables huh it's like when a
there's a Titanic Lifeboat and they're
getting away from the Titanic but the
Titanics go down it's so big the mass is
so big that they're just like and it
falls on top of it yeah can't get away I
think the thing Tian didn't happen not a
lot of people realize is that like for
Anthony like cuz I was kind of from the
same sort of friend circle like just on
the opposite side of him you were in the
winter Circle yeah oh that's a good way
of putting it but
like as all of the friends around were
like doing really big things like in
dance and achieving all his [__] even
though he wasn't in that first run of
[__] he showed up to everyone's stuff
and supported it and that means a lot
instead of just being jealous or being
like Oh that's not me or that's your
guys' thing he was in the audience for
like Mike's [__] he was like everywhere
like and super supportive I usually
don't like dancers dop but like when
Anthony came through same the thing I
liked about Anthony is it was effortless
to be friends with him and we can always
like continue and pick up where we left
off off cuz there'll be stretches of
time where we don't even see each other
for months and it's like he has a
comfortable vibe to him where just like
it's like right there like we would be
we would we known each other for many
years from JK films doing skits all this
stuff and then like there's some people
where you don't have to talk to them
every [__] day to feel like
comfortable around them amen yeah yeah
that's true and I think that's cool cuz
I I I didn't realize oh [__] we've known
each other for years bro but then I
never took the time to really get to
know you because I felt like I already
know you and and it sounds like [__]
weird but you know what I mean right it
feels like I already know this guy and I
don't have
to tell me who the real Anthony is you
know yeah yeah I think that's a good
trait to have it is yeah even with the
with like our two Crews and we were both
just [__] Rising like this and then
Ken just goes with [__] another
planet and [__] he's still like hey come
check out our thing come to our thing
come he's like always inv invting me to
stuff and my dude that's [__] nice
man he didn't big time you he didn't be
like no never that'se you you you got
you won the battle but you didn't win
the war
bit nice nice yeah that's cool Nick what
do you love about Anthony Lee you know
what I am actually quite intimidated by
Anthony Lee okay you're a little scary
first time I met you okay and I was I
was very like this guy is like a he's
like a big deal this guy that's what I
really thought and I was kind of like
afraid to talk to you a little bit I'm
being honest and I still am a little
bit so be friends with me I don't
believe that no I'm serious first all I
met him I was you're still afraid no I
was like that too when I first met him
because intimidating yeah because he's
just quick yeah dude like he mov F like
that no just like he was witty I I
wasn't have witty back then that was
like I met you like 200 you know out of
all the out of all the people that I
know my younger like cousins and nephews
and nieces they're the most excited
about you that I know wow cuz the new
gener like you know like like cuz he
dances with Jackson W yeah cuz our in
our generation if you danced you got
beat up but then now everyone danc now
everyone dances like and everyone knows
how to dance really good so dance is so
much bigger all of my nephews like out
of all the people that I know have come
across in contact they're like oh dude
you know the leader of The KES dude I
brag about you all the time I'm like I
know that guy dude pretty cool man I I
have the same tattoo with him that's I
think we met him in Australia first not
Stanford no but I didn't get to know him
though you didn't like him at first I
didn't like him so that's I actually
after all you guys were intimidated how
I remember all the [__]
stories [__] but I'm going to call
him out let him tell his story they'll
call him out but the first time I met
Anthony I actually liked Anthony out of
the group that he was with cuz he was
the guy that would actually talk to me
yeah I I think I slept at 10:00 so I
didn't even get a chance to and you got
the flu while you were there I did that
was crazy but in all seriousness I do I
do feel
like we've definitely built a
relationship over the years of us being
on the
show and that's all I'll say no we just
built a relationship a relationship it
just it's just I do I I I feel the same
sentiment as like what Ryan feels of
like you're this big boss you know CEO
type of guy but you are very cool to
talk to and very down to earth and I
feel like you should be that I feel like
you have all the rights to be kind of
the most downest [__] ever
that's what I mean like you're you're a
writer he did all the gay parts for JK
films when we needed a gay character he
cuz he was just down for fun [__] do
NC also when you invited me to Vibe and
I couldn't go I really felt bad I felt
really bad I couldn't go and I felt like
I was letting you down and I'm sorry I
couldn't go cuz I know feel that
important you know why you should go
next time because seeing him host by
himself on a stage age is actually
really [__] impressive no I bet i'
probably be really good and I've been
telling him that for so long I'm like
dude you're really good at this thing
all he's very good at hosting I'll go
next
time he got me extra tickets for me and
Tiff and I felt really bad I such a Joe
Vibe is the original all and gave you
extra tickets Vibe happening uh either
the end of January or February it's
around there it's just I was never
invited I'll go next time time yeah
that's what I did
that's get the [__] out of here so it's
right though like you you've lived a lot
of accomplishments that like even one of
your branches of something you've did in
dance is like one dancer's whole career
but you've like tasted the rainbow so
many different directions yeah so many
different ways you've done 911 different
things that successfully daners have it
done successfully have it done 91 things
this is literally the most emotionally
confusing dude just accept it ever been
a part of this feels like it feels like
I'm in like the opposite of Hot Seat
where it's the same feeling but I don't
get to say anything say something it's
like the roast and I got to I got to
admit like you guys get me emotional
you're also drunk he's drunk as
[__] he not he's not it's the roast of
Anthony Lee but it's not even a roast
it's like the toast the toast toast
toast toast the toast the toast Anthony
Le let's pay homage to his dedication of
denying line 911 which we love which we
think is fun that's probably one my
favorite things about you I you know
what I genuinely thank you for all that
warm [__] that you guys made me feel
right now even though it started off in
a place where I was very very [__]
confused and scared about like the
future of my brand because if there's
anything that's deterred fans in a
certain way it's been JK you guys have
been historically notorious are you
sure no detering is not the right word
more like mutate a lot of it I was a lot
of it oh okay I see that I see that we
added fans to you absolutely but in a
mutation sort of way yeah I see like
more fans who are down to like in public
say like hey this guy thinks N1 is
[__] would you rather that or them
being like the big and scary world now
for me and but you know that's what you
guys helped ground me even more my
favorite thing my favorite thing is when
he's like sometimes fans look at me and
they're like he's like the people are
like oh wow oh oh anthon and then some f
look at me they're
like oh no and he's like I always know
that that's a JK fan I know I know oh
no the next subset of fans the next
subset of fans that you're going to like
cultivate is going to be like the 911
deniers that are going to hold you as
king dude they're you're spreading our
message we love
[Music]
you